The answer is, get the x and y values from the friend parameter. Friend is a
person object. And we've added x and y instance variables to all of the person
objects. The line should join our object to the friend it's adding. We can't
just use our own instance variables, x and y. Because then our line would start
and end at the same point, and wouldn't join both friends. We can't just use
the friend parameter. Because this isn't specific enough. We can't use x coord
and y coord. Because those variables aren't accessible anymore. And they
contain the first endpoint, not the second endpoint. We could add parameters to
the addFriend method to take in the second endpoint of the line. But then every
time someone called addFriend, they would have to pass in the coordinates of
the friend they're adding. That would make the Person class harder to use.